en voilà donc pour les propos du
président zelensky devenu un héros en
seulement six mois auprès de son peuple
cette guerre en ukraine elle a déclenché
la plus grande crise de réfugiés en
europe depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
les chiffres de l' agence des nations
unies pour les réfugiés le hr sont
éloquents 6 millions 600 mille déplacés
ukrainien sur tout le continent avec
nous pour en parler à maghama cool
bonjour vous êtes rédactrice en chef
d'un faux migrants ici à france 24 où se
trouvent ses plus de six millions et
demi de réfugiés d'exilés ukrainien
aujourd'hui alors il s'agit d'un chef
qui concerne l'europe donc sur ces six
millions et demi en a 2 millions en
russie étonnamment alors leur situation
a eu son parti est particulière parce
que kiev et moscou sont pas d'accord sur
sur la version 2 pourquoi il se trouve
là moscou affirme que s'il ya des lieux
d'hébergement temporaires qui ont été
mis en place pour mettre à l'abri des
civils ukrainien qui auraient fui et
kiev dit que ces citoyens auraient été
déportés dans des camps par les russes
donc accepté ce cas particulier la
grande partie la grande majorité des
déplacés s'est installé dans les pays
limitrophes de l'ukraine principalement
en pologne mais aussi en roumanie en
république tchèque la pologne est donc
le premier pays d'accueil avec plus de
1,2 million de déplacés ukrainien
l'allemagne prend aussi sa part avec un
peu moins d'un million de réfugiés et la
république tchèque en compte 400 milles
la france est il loin derrière on va on
va en reparler il ya aussi ceux qui
décident de de revenir en ukraine malgré
la guerre oui mais alors ce n'est pas
encore un retour massif on en parle
c'est vrai parce que depuis le mois de
mai environ 35000 personnes entrent
chaque jour en ukraine mais il faut
aussi regarder le chiffre des départs il
a beaucoup baissé depuis l'exode massif
qu'on avait vu au premier jour aux
premières semaines de la guerre pour se
stabiliser à environ 50 milles personnes
qui quittent le pays depuis le mois
d'avril chaque jour donc malgré tout six
mois après la guerre il ya plus de
personnes qui quittent le pays que deux
personnes qui rentrent qu'en est il de
la france amara quelle est la situation
des ukrainiens qui sont accueillis dans
l'hexagone on parle de 200 mille
personnes c'est ça un peu plus de 5000
oui alors elle est plutôt bonne ils sont
hébergés ces cent mille personnes pour
la moitié pendant des structures de
l'état ou des collectivités
territoriales l'autre moitié est hébergé
chez l'habitant dans des trucs de faim
avec des organismes d'hébergement
solidaire ou bien c'est des personnes de
la communauté ukrainienne ou des proches
comme tous les réfugiés ukrainien en
europe les réfugiés craignais en france
et les résidents de longue durée en
ukraine bénéficie de la protection
temporaire mise en place par l'union
européenne c'est une mesure très rare et
et qu'on n'avait pas vu dans les
précédents conflits c'est à dire que
l'ue a décidé de donner cette protection
pour six mois renouvelable deux fois à
aux réfugiés ukrainien donc à leur
permet de 18 mois jusqu'à 18 mois en
tout donc là elle va être renouvelée
donc elle leur permet de résider
légalement dans un pays de l'union
européenne mais également d'avoir une
protection médicale une allocation est
aussi d'avoir accès au marché de
l'emploi alors ce point-là être
difficile encore pour multiples raisons
en france notamment ils ne travaillent
pas encore beaucoup pourquoi parce que
déjà il ya la barrière de la langue et
puis pour eux pour pour les réfugiés
ukrainien liga leur particularité ce ne
sont pas des personnes qui souhaitent
rester c'est un conflit qu'il souhaite
se terminer rapidement
un sondage publié par l'onu en juillet
montrait que majoritairement il voulait
rentrer dès que le conflit le
permettrait en fait dès l'arrêt des
hostilités et puis c est majoritairement
des femmes avec des enfants jeunes qui
sont là nokia pas les pères il n'ya pas
les garçons de plus de 17 ans ils sont
restés combattre voilà ça c'est le
directeur de l'oph idylis chi chi le
soulignait ce matin sur l'antenne de nos
collègues de rfi et ces personnes en
face à ces femmes pour elle s'installe
et apprendre la langue et trouver un
travail s'est s'installé pour elle ce
serait peut-être préfigurer la défaite
de leur pays et ça elle ne le souhaite
pas mais on le rappelle un ce conflit en
ukraine selon tous les observateurs il
devrait durer encore plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années merci beaucoup
amara pour tous ces éléments